البرد القارص بدا يتسلل الى اوكرانيا وليس
في منطقه خرسون المحرره حديثا من القبضه
الروسيه لا كهرباء ولا ماء للشرب
عن عظام للامان في ظل استمرار القصف
المدفعي الروسي على خير
الاقل
تاثر بنيران الروسيه ووفرت لهم وسائل نقل
مع اعطاء الاولويه لكبار السن والامهات مع
اولادهن الحصول على ماخذين الكهرباء ونيل
قصه من الدفاره يوميا بالنسبه الى سكان
رئيس الاداره العسكريه في جنوب اوكرانيا
حاول تطمن الناس صدقوني الجيش الاوكراني
يبطل اقصى جهده نحن نواجه حثاله وعلينا ان
نتصرف بطريقه افضل من تدمير والبنيه
التحتيه لقطاع الطاقه الاوكراني سيكون له
تاثير خطير على حياه السكان منظمه الصحه
العالميه حظرت من انتشار الامراض التنفسيه
بسبب البرد واستخدام الحرق كوسيله للتدفئه
طعاما لمده اسبوع ل 2500 شخص سلمون نحو
2030 مصباح يعمل على طاقه شمسيه لاضاءه
المنازل لان خلص معزوله عن امداداته
الطاقه ولا تتوفر فيها مواد النظافه
من يقدر على السفر الى خارج البلاد من اجل
ادخال الطاقه وتوفيرها لاستمرار عمل
المستشفيات والمرافق العامه
[موسيقى]